octorok Spock ah blends moblins lizalfos
Keese henyk sees Lionel's you know what
all of these famous enemies from the
Zelda franchise have in common they're
all monsters like non-human monsters
like hey I'm a pig person or I'm a bat
with one eye kind of non-human we've all
grown to know and love these monsters
well love destroying them in glorious
combat engines but for those of you who
are new to Zelda or have only played the
newest game breath to the wild you may
not know that there's a particular enemy
in particular that's particularly
non-monster meet the dark nut these
massive humanoid-looking enemies are
clad head-to-toe in several layers of
massive plate armor and normally wield
massive weapons used for the art of a
massacre sometimes they even have
shields to the first time you fight a
dark nut in Wind Waker
or Twilight Princess it's as a mini boss
of a dungeon because even though more
experienced players can defeat the giant
Knights pretty easily if you don't know
how to fight them they can prove to be
deadly opponents indeed these tough boys
have made several appearances across the
franchise from the original Legend of
Zelda to Wind Waker to Twilight Princess
and in today's video I'm gonna explore
everything we know about the dark nuts
in order to connect them to our one and
only hero himself if you're doubtfully
squinting at the screen right now just
wait until the end of the video the
evidence will surprise you and by the
way for the more savvy of you watching
this I'm specifically talking about dark
nuts not their closely resembled cousin
the iron knuckles if you guys would like
for me to talk about the knuckles let me
know in a comment after the video and
also real quick before we delve into the
content if you're not subscribed to the
channel yet make sure you are with that
Bell icon for some exciting new content
coming right here to the channel
actually I made a channel update video
about some really cool announcements and
thank-yous that's live right now so if
you've got the time please be sure to
check that out after this video the
links to it will be in the description
and on the screen right now and that's
enough of that on to the content one of
the first things to note about dark nuts
is both how similarly they appear across
the games but also how differently and
we probably need to cover this before
getting into their potential connections
to the hero himself the dark nuts from
the Minish
in the Wind Waker when their helmets are
knocked off reveal that even though they
have humanoid bodies they have
straight-up
Anubis like jackal heads instead of you
know person like heads pretty monstrous
indeed but I said they were human-like
earlier right right because in Twilight
Princess when you knock their helmets
off guess what they have human heads I
mean unless their ears are very neatly
folded back into their chainmail and
their snouts are being squished by those
masks so what's with this head
difference anyway well before we get
into their differing appearances we
first need to determine what exactly
dark nuts are or rather who exactly they
were before serving the forces of demise
the most common theory for the dark nuts
true identities or hidden pasts is that
they were none other than the Knights of
Hyrule also known as the Hylian Knights
but we're unfortunately corrupted by
demises hatred there is actually a lot
of evidence to support this besides the
fact that you know with their
intelligent martial arts are more
weaponry and human-like forms they kind
of stand out from the other monsters of
Ganon's army in general in Twilight
Princess they're only found in the
temple of time and hyrule castle itself
which are two locations that would
probably realistically be guarded by
Hylian Knights
given that the former location guards
the master sword and the latter guards
you know Princess Zelda and the Hylian
throne of royalty which is what they are
sworn to protect as Knights they're also
very tall which is a similarity they
share with the armor sets present
throughout Hyrule Castle in Twilight
Princess and do make note that these are
armor sets that are set on display and
not statues like we see in other games
yet the dark nuts are the only people
tall enough to wear them besides
Ganondorf from the hero shade but I'm
getting ahead of myself
speaking of their armor well one it
isn't the armor present on display
throughout the castle and it doesn't
bear any super obvious Triforce symbol
anywhere on its surface there are
multiple very loftwing esque designs
present all over their armor and at the
tip of their swords which is the bird
that is commonly used to symbolize
Hyrule or hylians in general and really
how much more Knightly can their armor
be they have multiple pieces of heavy
plate armor covering head to
Oh face covering helmets a layer of
underlying chainmail and a lighter sword
for use in close quarters combat even if
dark nuts weren't called dark nuts we'd
probably end up calling these guys some
sort of Knights because of their
equipment alone in Wind Waker which does
admittedly feature that jackal-headed
dark nuts which I will get to in just a
sec
they each wear and drop a very
significant piece of equipment called
the Knights crest based on their name
and a description given by an NPC
in-game we know that the owners of said
crests were Knights and these Knights
crests are well known by the old man
named Orca on outside Island who states
that the crests in order to be gathered
or held must be obtained by a courageous
knight that possesses not only courage
but power and wisdom as well if that
doesn't alarmingly link the Knights
crests to the fabled Knights of Hyrule I
don't know what does the only question
that remains is are the Knights crests
that dark nuts where stolen or do they
actually belong to the dark nuts
themselves well to me logically speaking
since every Dark Knight and Wind Waker
has a knight's crest and has clearly
been intelligently trained for combat I
think it's more believable to think that
the crests belong to the dark nuts
rather than you know every single
darkness just so happened to steal every
other Knights crest and just so happy to
be trained like a knight don't you think
so given their armor design and nightly
equipment and training we see in both
Wind Waker and Twilight Princess and
their locations as enemies I tend to
believe that dark nuts are none other
than corrupted Knights of Hyrule I mean
we even see directly that the Knights
have been corrupted before like in the
game for swords adventures when you have
to fight the four corrupted Hylian
Knights that were even transformed into
monsters a cool little possible extra
piece of evidence to further support
this would be the fact that the dark
nuts original Japanese name Totten aku
ends in a katakana symbol which is what
the Japanese used to indicate the
borrowing of a word it's possible that
the original name was meant to be dark
night instead of dark nut but on the
same note the Japanese name for the
similar iron knuckle is Iona ku meaning
either the iron knuckles may have been
actually named iron knight
or iron nuts or the dark nuts may have
been dark knuckles or dark nights anyway
as confusing as that was I just thought
that was a neat little piece of naming
conspiracy so the dark nuts are probably
corrupted Hylian Knights that's cool and
all but what's that got to do with link
great question really thanks for asking
it's long been hinted at and even
confirmed in more than just one of the
games that link is actually a descendant
of the Knights of Hyrule who are a
devoted people group dedicated to the
protection of the royal family whose
lineage is passed down in their
bloodline the most commonly acclaimed
piece of evidence to support this would
be the link from a Link to the Past or
more specifically his uncle you see when
zelda uses her telepathy at the
beginning of the game to contact Link's
uncle and by extension link himself it's
revealed that she was actually trying to
get ahold of the Knights of Hyrule who
were the sworn protectors of the royal
family since link is a member of the
Knightly bloodline he was contacted as
well as his uncle secondly in the most
recent installment of breath of the wild
link is again straight-up confirmed to
be a member of the Hylian nights since
zelda claims that his father was also a
knight other instances we can deduce
links connections to the Knights of
Hyrule would be like an ocarina of time
when it's explained that Link's mother
was running from the current war with
her baby in her arms
many fans presume links father was a
knight fighting in battle at the time
and probably passed away as a result
tragically so since link is oftentimes
associated with the Knights of Hyrule
and the Knights are stated to be
descendants of the original hero and the
Dartmouth's are probably Knights
themselves what if link is actually
related by blood to the darkness we see
across all the games I mean it could
help to explain why dark nuts are so bad
to the bone but another question that
may come up is if the dark nuts and
Hylian Knight armors we see are always
so you know huge then how could the
normally short link be possibly of the
same bloodline I actually do have a
guess at that and be warned this next
portion is pretty speculative stuff okay
so you know how in Twilight Princess the
hero shade appears to give the hero of
Twilight some pointers on how to swing a
sword and Hyrule historia went on to
confirm that the hero shade is actually
the hero of time from ocarina of time
did the height difference
strike you as odd I mean look at the
shade he's massive
he Dwarfs the hero of Twilight by
several feet at least using link as a
comparison the shade is actually right
around the same size of a dark nut and
his armor though bearing different
designs is structurally strikingly
similar to dark nut Armour what would
that plumed helmet chainmail layer and
circular shield but how is this height
possible if he's supposed to be Link's
ancestor the hero of time from ocarina
of time who is clearly not that huge
in-game and by the way side note but
important note the hero shade is a shade
not a stalfos he's a ghost or Spectre of
the hero of time I don't want to make
this video a twenty-plus long video so
I'm not gonna take the time to go into
the differences but if you'd like a more
in-depth look on the shade himself and
my theory as to what happened to him
feel free to check out this theory at
the card on the screen or by the link in
the description below but anyway what
age do boys normally stop growing
1819 I mean me personally I stopped at
the ripe age of eleven but I was always
just big for my age link in Ocarina of
Time is either 16 or 17 years old as an
adult there is a possibility that he
could have grown for another year or so
after the age we see him as an adult
in-game also his appearance in Twilight
Princess takes place in the child
timeline meaning link was sent back to
his original timeline and then was able
to grow up in those 7 years that we
otherwise skipped over in the adult
timeline and was free to eat and drink
and sleep properly instead of just being
sealed away what if his nutritional
intake was different and unlocked his
ability to grow to his true height from
his nightly Blood combine his height
with his nightly armor and you've got
yourself link the hero of time knight of
hyrule ancestor to the hero of Twilight
and the dark nuts and that is my theory
on Link's relationship to the dark nuts
of The Legend of Zelda but wait I almost
forgot to cover something I'm glad I
decided to script it in at the last
minute including these comments I'm
reading right now oh wait let me skip
forward a bit real quick I wanted to
touch on the fact that I believe the
differing head design for dark nuts in
the Minish Cap and wind waker is simply
a line of Hylian
it's that were indeed cursed to be dark
nuts but instead of being cursed by
Ganon and appearing like the dark nuts
we see in Twilight Princess they were
cursed by Vaati who also turned them
into the jackal like beings we see them
as in those two games I don't
necessarily have much proof for this
little mini theory other than the fact
that I believe the jackal dark nuts were
in fact Knights of Hyrule and Vaati is
pretty well known for being able to
transform himself others and even the
entirety of Hyrule Castle
so a transformative curse seems pretty
well within his powers I mean I suppose
it is possible that even the darkness
from Twilight Princess and all other
appearances are also jackal heads under
those helmets but I don't know looking
at the Twilight Princess dark nuts just
makes it hard for me to imagine longears
being folded back somewhere under that
chainmail and their long nose is being
squished into those masks but maybe
that's just me
what do you think let me know in the
comments below hey guys thank you so
much for watching be sure to LIKE this
video if you enjoyed watching and
subscribe if you haven't already for
some awesome stuff to come as always
huge thanks to my amazing patrons who
make my day every day and I even have
some new additions to my elite crew meet
Nova crystal and teeth who have decided
to support my channel with the utmost of
generosity if you're interested in
getting your name up here at the end of
all my videos feel free to check out the
link in the description below or check
out my other video I just uploaded
detailing some pretty cool stuff coming
to the channel including another way to
get your name up here and you don't even
have to leave youtube also down the
description are the links to my social
media pages so come on over and say hi
this is Mastana Bandits signing out wash
your hands out there people and stay
safe peace
[Music]